who would have ever dreamed a year ago
august 13 we'd be talking about philip
rivers as the starting quarterback of
the indianapolis colts but it was august
24
of 2019 when the bomb was dropped on
indianapolis and the rest of the nfl
with andrew luck retiring out of the
blue so now it's philip rivers the colts
now right there at the bottom of the top
half a team that i think a lot of people
may just be uncertain about i'm
uncertain about them sure you got them
higher than the texans the the defending
champions in the division but i still
don't know which way they're going to go
i think that's why middle is good for
them they could go up they could go down
but they're probably not going to be 16
when it's all said and done chris no i
don't think so either and you know i
think if you ask me right now i'd expect
them to go up just to just sit in here
you know in early or mid-august whatever
we're talking about here hey last year
was tough of course it was i mean they
lost one of the 10 best players in
football right before the season was
going to start so that's going to throw
a little wrench into your franchise and
and and how things go that way um so you
know
we we have to remember that but
replacing andrew luck getting a phillip
rivers who we know can do some really
awesome things still we hope he doesn't
do some of the bad things is what we're
you know hoping doesn't happen to the
indianapolis colts and and philip rivers
with the careless interceptions we saw
but man i mean mike i look at the colts
and go
you know my big thing was wow chris
ballard you know frank reich they have
done an unbelievable job building that
roster there is great depth there's a
lot of under the radar talent to me the
one thing they have missed is difference
making playmakers on both sides of the
ball and they kind of address that this
offseason to where i go ooh now i'm very
bullish on the colts you know hey who's
the guy that was going to make a play at
the end of a football game or in a big
moment i don't know who it was but now
they got deforest buckner i can promise
you he'll show up in some of those
moments no doubt about it you know
offensive side of the ball hey they had
t.y hilton but if he was hurt you were
like damn who that what the hell the
colts gonna do on offense you know what
are they gonna do
now they've addressed it got michael
pittman jr stood at a usc wide receiver
could have been a first round pick then
you know they get the running back uh
jonathan taylor out of wisconsin home
run hitter and then you add that with
philip rivers and his ability to push
the ball down the field and be
aggressive that way i think it kind of
changes the dynamic of their football
team a little bit and you know mike i'm
with you i think they're a dangerous
team certainly and in a tough division
but i won't be shocked if they're in the
playoffs when all said and done
and we can rattle off player after
player after player but it all comes
down to the quarterback the most
important position on any football team
phillip rivers had 32 touchdown passes
and 12 interceptions in 2018. last year
it was 23 td 20 int and i think the
thing that
influences me more than anything else
and i freely admit it i'm probably
putting too much emphasis on it but when
i see back to back primetime games with
a total of seven interceptions thrown by
philip rivers and we get to watch that
throwing motion again and again and
again and that arm is just not what it
used to be at least when he's throwing
it to the other team you get that into
your brain and you can't get rid of it
the only way to get rid of it is to get
him back in a couple of prime time games
where he has seven touchdown passes
right in two games not seven
interceptions chris which phillip rivers
are the cults going to get yeah well he
played on the edge last year and didn't
necessarily need to do that because they
had a defense that could have kept them
in football games and you're right those
those end of the game interceptions in
prime time and things like we talked
about you just mentioned i mean yeah
they're in our brain they definitely are
let alone there's a handful of games
where he started off the game being
careless with the football and put them
in the hole to where it was hard for
them to come back so you know yes i
don't know what phillip rivers were
going to see the one thing i think that
frank reich will beat into his brain is
you don't have to do it all yourself we
have an unbelievable offensive line
maybe the best in football frank reich
will stay patient with the run game and
then what i really think is sneaky about
this team
if they got a t y hilton healthy
paris campbell from the 2019 draft at
ohio state a guy that has a rocket up
his butt mike i mean a guy that can
catch a screen pass and go 80 yards down
the sideline like we saw him do against
michigan his senior year or junior year
in college and then with michael pittman
jr and jonathan taylor i just look at
that to go damn you got that skill set
with that offensive line they can do
some special things and hopefully he
won't have to push the envelope of i
need to make a play for my team and do
that and i think they should be sitting
pretty when all said and done if he can
play you know the position true to form
horseshoe on his helmet rock it up his
butt that's paris campbell let me jump
ahead here on the outline since you
mentioned paris campbell who led the
colts in receiving yards last year chris
oh man that is a real i was
is it is it zach pascal i mean am i my
right i don't even know but i'm i'm
i'm going to go with that you you are
you are correct and i am going to assume
that when pete demolitis pressed the
button to tell it to me he accidentally
pressed the button to tell it to you as
well no way no way i live this crap and
i don't even need to look at stats i
just go through my rolodex in my brain
and go damn i remember watching film a
lot and him catching a lot of passes
how many yards did he have oh
smart guy yeah i know he didn't have i
don't i know he didn't have a thousand
at least i'm hoping he'd i'm gonna say
it was like seven
748 755 anywhere in there
now if this was the price is right you
would be you would be gone but it was
607. so that's close enough we're not
going to go bob barker rolls here you
can be over by a little bit that's
impressive all right also impressive the
wall that they have built in
indianapolis that big blue wall anchored
by quentin nelson who has been a godsend
for that unit in his two years in the
nfl
do you have
or do you prefer if you're a quarterback
to have that kind of a line or would you
rather have the kind of weapons that a
tom brady walked into in tampa bay oh
it is it's it's tough but
i would say i'd rather have the line i
would and then that's not easy to say as
a quarterback
but you know there's there's ways to
make receivers and skill guys look a
little bit better than they are through
scheme and play design and things like
that you know
if you don't have blocking up front a
little bit of a run game to scare people
and pass you know time and pass
protection and things like that
it's hard to do anything on the
offensive side of the ball so as much as
i love great receivers and all that i
think i would take the offensive line
and here's the thing if you have a great
offense offensive line what happens is
your receivers who previously weren't
all that great exactly become great
exactly they start catching a lot of
passes and generating old yards and we
start talking about them and we have an
elevated impression of how good they are
because the quarterback has unlimited
time exactly and they have time to get
open and he's got time to find them and
that's why offensive linemen never get
enough credit because when the offensive
line is working to perfection
you've got plenty of other guys that get
pumped up with their stats with their
profile with everything with their
salaries and uh yeah that that great
line leads to
great skill position players i yeah even
though mike evans chris goddard i know
i know
i still agree with you because we'll be
rattling off the colts
receivers in tight ends with that same
reverence next year if philip rivers can
find them uh given the benefit of the
time that he's he's gonna i mean look
nothing against the chargers offensive
line over the last 16 years but i don't
think he's had an offensive line as good
as the one he's about to be lining up
behind no not even close and especially
you know the last two years especially
last year i mean last year was one of
the more poor offensive lines in all
football out there with the chargers and
i think that led to him trying to do too
much at times maybe holding the ball a
little longer than he should with that
group around him all that but mike like
i think you're spot on you know with
what you're saying think about a guy
like t.y hilton oh we want to run like a
long developing route right a post
corner run straight for 12 yards post it
for another six yards you know to 18
yards total now come back out of the
corner route at that 18 19 yard mark and
run you know to a high angle 25 30 yards
down the field you know that's great he
could burn people all day you got crappy
offensive line protection quarterbacks
never gonna have time to see you come
out of those breaks or get open now you
go vice versa there and go oh the
quarterback has time yeah of course now
now ty hilton can sell those routes but
even when you have time and the defense
covers it well
right now oh an extra pat on the ball ty
hilton comes out of the break he
realizes whoa i'm kind of in a bad spot
they got me covered let me adjust i see
my quarterback still sitting there in
the pocket and then bam it ends up being
a 20 yard completion and we don't even
like you said we don't even care we
don't even go oty hilton didn't get open
you know we just go hey great job by
them they got it done so yeah the colts
are you know
i guess another one of those teams mike
i'm gonna throw in there you know we've
talked about the browns the chargers you
know i think the rams i'm missing
another team in there that we've gone
over recently to where i go didn't make
the playoffs last year but would be a
prime candidate for one of those teams
to say here's the turnover here in 2020
and they're a part of the playoffs this
year i would think they're towards the
top of the list in that combo well i
think the falcons were another team yeah
that's right in that category as well
finishing six and two and and remember
and look
we
i don't think we can fully grasp this
yet because we've never lived through a
season with seven playoff spots per
conference
but we will see
what it means to have that one extra
spot and how many other teams are going
to be in play for that spot they're
going to be playoff contenders that's
why there wasn't a single coach that was
against expanding to seven
because you know if the mandate is
playoffs or else you got one more shot
to get to the playoffs and if the
mandate is playoff contention
pretty much everybody's going to be in
contention except a couple of teams when
we get into the middle of december
best case worst case for the
indianapolis colts chris in 2020.
[Music]
best case is they they're they can win
the division i i i won't you know if
we're sitting here at the end of
december and we go man the colts won the
division they were 12 and four and 11
five or i i think that could be the best
case scenario i don't think that's crazy
worst case
i just can't see the wheels falling off
this team there's too much talent and
depth on the team to where even if they
had a few bad injuries they got enough
players behind it to still be
respectable so i'm gonna say worst case
is like seven and nine you know i don't
think it can get any worse than that
with the coaching staff the guys they
got on the team and now philip rivers i
i feel confident in that
well and look the wheels fell off last
year in a way that no one could have
anticipated with andrew luck retiring i
don't think phillip rivers is going to
retire on august 24 of this year worst
case in my mind would be
something in the range of six or seven
wins but i'm with you i think they're
more likely to be good they're more
likely to be above 500 and the best case
would be kind of a hey everything has
lined up just perfectly this year
phillip rivers has a career rebirth in
indianapolis and you know they go 12 and
4. and they're in
roundabout rough contention
for one of the top two seeds although as
we talked about yesterday only the top
seed matters this year because no one
else gets a bye but uh hey i
yeah get ready because that afc south is
going to be fascinating this year
the titans were a final four team last
year and they're they're like an
afterthought when we focus on the colts
and the texans in that division but the
titans still not revealed on the
preseason power rankings they will be
coming at some point in the top half of
the list
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports